[Music]
thank you
foreign
I've been investigating drug traffickers
for over 15 years often I'm alone female
journalist surrounded by masked
criminals 99 of whom are men it's
starting to boil and the Crystal is
starting to form at the top
but recently I've heard Tales of a new
breed of Narco trafficker
women
[Music]
has it these Brash cocaine Queens
are helping revolutionize the
multi-billion dollar drug business
and I'm on a mission to find them
[Music]
we'll call my driver Louise he's a real
native whose family has connections to
the city's criminal underworlds
Massachusetts
foreign
[Music]
she calls herself Hello Kitty just 21
years old she's one of the most Wanted
drug traffickers in all of Brazil
the prime suspect in multiple armed
robberies and murder
and a rising cocaine distributor for one
of the country's most powerful drugs
[Music]
and my sources say she's holed up in
Rio's favelas
slums and Shanty towns that house more
than 1.5 million people
nearly a quarter of the City's
population
so we're entering the Favela right now
I have to stop because there's these
barriers that exist at the entrance
if anyone is trying to invade it will
slow down any Invasion by the police or
rival Organics
so this is the things that you have to
do when you enter the Villa turn on the
lights you see the hazard lights are on
stop okay
foreign
s boast that God made the world in six
days
and the seventh he devoted to Rio De
Janeiro
they're not talking about the prevalence
they're talking about this
but there's a flip side to these
sugar-coated pictures
kind of Tale of Two Cities
extreme poverty fuels Brazil's Black
Market
so much so that today after the United
States Brazil is the world's largest
cocaine consumer
[Music]
I've lived in Rio and have spent time in
many favelas places where crack wheat
cocaine and other illegal substances are
sold out in the open
to safeguard the drug markets these
slums are protected by criminal gangs
and their Gatekeepers people like this
woman
it's rare to see a woman in a row like
this
here I am talking with this gang member
in front of her kids
she tells me to call her pirigaza which
means dangerous
[Music]
foreign
24-hour surveillance Network
comprised of 21 Lookouts
called hajins Portuguese for the little
radiance
they are the eyes and ears of the Narco
traffickers
favelas are like thiefdoms most are
controlled by powerful gangs
pitigans people monitor all entries and
exits so they can alert the gang
leadership of any Invasion by rivals or
cops
despite her key position pirigaza is
judged by her neighbors
foreign
[Music]
who truly rise through the ranks are the
ones who put down their walkie-talkie
and pick up a gun
and if I want to find a cocaine Queen
like Hello Kitty
I need to get closer to the products
time to pound the pavement
Louise's uncle was a founding member of
the country's oldest drug Inc comando
Vermeil the red command
the same gang Hello Kitty is set to work
for I think it's here
so that's where we start
Ed
I shouldn't be surprised Rio is a city
of some seven million people
and the red command has many factions
on easy finding one woman
even after the Gang has opened their
doors to me
anymore
foreign
[Music]
the red command
one of three trafficking organizations
that controls all of the cocaine in
Brazil
what I'm discovering is that over the
past two decades Brazil leveraged its
location bordering every coca producing
country to become a global distributor
while Mexico's cartels move cocaine into
the United States Brazil's Gans are now
the top suppliers to Europe and Africa
but a lot of this powder remains right
here
to satisfy the growing appetites of Rios
rich
and poor
they have this little spoon and they
basically put the cocaine inside these
little bags and this sells for five of
the eyes which is currently worth a
dollar and it's mostly sold in this
neighborhood and neighborhoods around
here
it's possible the cocaine I'm looking at
will be sold by Hello Kitty herself
she works for the same gang as these
guys
so he was actually in prison recently
and he's saying that even in prison they
talked about her a lot that she was
really good she's a really good soldier
Maestra believes that today's women have
a unique advantage
the element of surprise
cops still assume that cocaine
traffickers look like Pablo Escobar not
like Hello Kitty he says that the police
is really targeting the men here so
there's not going to be a lot of men
around to do this kind of work so it'll
be up to the women to do it
foreign
oh my God
this is not Hello Kitty
I'm still working my way up Commando
vermeil's chain of command
but she is proof that while women don't
yet rule Wheels cocaine Market
thank you
they are far more female narcos than I
ever imagined
because
she calls herself buyer after her
favorite Socrates
just 25 years old Bayern came up again
cocaine was expanding its reach
throughout Brazil
now she's a soldado a narco soldier who
provides security for the red demand
[Music]
I have to admit
admin crafts like Hello Kitty she's a
woman who isn't just breaking the glass
ceiling she's literally shooting her way
through it
[Music]
I'm a Glock yeah
you know
is
[Music]
wow you see that she's showing me the
Bullet Hole the bullet came through this
side and came out of this side
these shootouts with law enforcement
have become all too common
as cocaine exploded throughout the
country so did gang violence today Rio's
police response involves helicopter-born
snipers with shoot to kill orders
in 2019 the police here killed over 1
800 people that's five people a day
nearly twice the number killed by cops
in the entire United States
still the traffickers eisement seemed to
take this violence and stride is
review
salvation
that depends on a person's point of view
tonight I'll have the chance to ask
Hello Kitty herself
my red command contacts have finally
come through
we're scheduled to meet her on her turf
care from what we've heard she's going
to be actually waiting for us in the
inside of this favelas we're driving
deeper and deeper
so please please please do not put the
cameras up he's asking
When we arrive at the Rendezvous Point
Louise receives new Intel from his
underworld sources
so not good news
um apparently we were told she was
waiting for us but then we got here and
apparently she's gone
[Music]
and it's uh we're being told that there
is going to be a police operation here
tomorrow
they found out through an informant they
have at the police and so when that
happens and the word spreads they go out
and they start hiding everything they
hide the guns and the drugs and that's
what apparently has happened tonight and
that's where she's disappeared and no
one couldn't find her
unfortunately the trail goes cold
dead cold
the police operation took place the
following day and we never re-engaged
with Hello Kitty
a few weeks later we received word that
Hello Kitty and her father were killed
in a gun battle with Rios police
yes she was an Unapologetic cocaine
Queen
but she was also 21 years old and mother
of two children
[Music]
cocaine has transformed Brazil's black
market and its players
but in the end I never got to meet the
female Narco boss I'm searching for
so I head to the source
the world's biggest cocaine producer
to locate a rumored Narco Queen the cops
and criminals are all trying to kill
[Music]
so you've been in touch with these
people I mean they know that we're
coming
I'm in touch with these groups but
you have to be careful Mariana
we are green lighted by them but I mean
at the end of the day they are criminals
the man riding shotgun is Oliver schmied
a local photojournalist who once helped
me gain access to the cocaine Highway
the 3 000 mile Journey Smuggler's take
to move their product from the mountains
of South America to Miami Beach
now we're trying to track down a female
Narco named Sonia
rumored to be the second in command one
of Colombia's newest criminal cartels
Los caparos
what do you guys know about her this
woman she's supposed to be the boss of
the Hitman in this area the boss of the
Assassin yeah which is like really
astonishing
astonishing is an understatement
you see for five decades Colombia has
been the world's biggest cocaine
producer
this multi-billion dollar Black Market
was dominated by one man
the king of cocaine Pablo Escobar
throughout the 70s 80s and 90s Escobar's
Medellin parkes controlled every Link in
their Global Supply Chain from
production to distribution
but when the Kingpin was gunned down in
is cartel crumbleds the cocaine business
however did not
it simply involved today Colombia
produces more powder than ever but the
big cartels have splintered into smaller
rival gangs
which means more competition and
violence
to fight back against the new generation
of narcos the Colombian government
offers money to local farmers to burn
their crops
a lot of Coca Growers they started to
destroy the Coca fields
but now the government is not fulfilling
the agreements and they're being
threatened to death by the drug dealers
Rumor Has It Sonia murdered one of these
farmers
then ordered her men to leave his body
on display
for 10 days
[Music]
feels very much like we're entering the
Heart of Darkness here you definitely
right Mariana
[Music]
the man holding the phone is Ivan
Vasquez a former Colombian Special
Forces Soldier and our security advisor
for the region
the voice on the other end is our
contact inside Sonia's gang
Nam
the region we're in is called bahukawka
it 2019 it had a murder rate on par with
Tijuana Mexico the violent city in the
world
just weeks ago eight teenage soccer
players traveling through here were
taken hostage
[Music]
they got kidnapped by the same gang we
are supposed to meet by Los Papados free
Cut fruit one day found dead already so
they were wait they were kidnapped by
the same people we are meeting yeah and
is there any guarantee that these people
are meeting us and that they're not
going to kidnap us do we well there's no
guarantee I mean you are under the
control of a criminal gank
there is a risk to get kidnapped
okay and that's when our contact calls
back
with a meeting point
instead of finding Sonia we're picked up
along the way by a pair of her sicarios
professional Hitman who order us to
follow them
foreign
[Music]
residents live in poverty today
Spanish conquistadors knew there was
tremendous wealth to be found here
hidden underground
as we follow the sicarios into this
mining operation I assume this is where
we'll find Sonia
[Music]
instead we discover the men are taking
us on a Shakedown
foreign
[Music]
s want us to leave immediately
but I want to know more about what's
Happening Here
before I can ask more questions my crew
alerts me that the gunmen are on the
phone with Sonia herself
is
it seems I've overstayed my welcome
[Music]
while her gunmen lead us away from the
mine
Ivan gets a concerning call from his
local security sources
over the past 24 hours there have been
multiple gun fights between local gangs
with six people confirmed killed so this
area right now he was saying it's super
super hot
it seems like every gang in bahukawka
wants a piece of the pie and they're
willing to kill for it
hello
they just
[Music]
gonna check all the cars make sure that
there's no one else there or any guns
he's also getting all the guns from our
security guys
I'm disarming everybody
[Music]
and no cell phones allowed in
once they take our cell phones they
order us to follow them it's time to
meet their leader La comandante the
commander you see he just handed the
money to him and he's the only one who's
able
to approach
her the woman he's about to give her
the money
it's amazing though she's the one really
giving the orders here yeah
in my many years of investigating Narco
traffickers this is the first time I've
encountered a woman who wields so much
power over Violent well-armed Men
okay
eventually I'm permitted to approach
Sonia
is
foreign
because there's not enough money it's
not the money that she was promised
well apparently there's like another
group close by and they're getting
scared okay
guys really for reals now we have to go
Groupon
Sonia's bodyguards rush her to safety
while they prepare for an imminent
attack oh my God the guy's got his gun
he just you know it's serious when they
start freaking out
my film crew and I are embedded with a
gang of cocaine traffickers and a rival
cartel is closing in
okay the mine where we were just now
filming there was another rival group
that came in armed so that things are
definitely not safe because this could
be the next next spot they target
hopefully this is open yeah
he started hearing gunshots right where
we came from
[Music]
this is
we flee the gang's compound I realize I
know next to nothing about their female
Commander a woman who every rival gang
in Bahu kauka sings to one dead
foreign
trafficking is a man's world
traditionally
almost never do you see a woman occupy a
position of power like Sonia
while there have been a few confirmed
gangster teams in recent history often
exaggerated by Hollywood the women I
typically interview are low-level drug
mules
but maybe these changes in the black
market shouldn't be so surprising the
fight for equality in the legal Market
has been happening for Generations
I imagine something similar must be
taking place inside organized crime
still how does a 21 year old woman end
up a cartel Commander
[Music]
foreign
the morning after the attack I
discovered Sonia's Sonia is just alive
turns out it was the clandel Golfo that
led the attack you can film there's
Sonia's main rival
the biggest drug traffickers in the
region with alleged links to Mexico
Sinaloa cartel
um
maintenance
Sonia is young but so is her group Los
caparos
they're one of the newest gangs
competing for Colombia's cocaine profits
supposedly created by former right-wing
paramilitaries who abandoned politics an
embraced crime
it is
okay sorry
Sonia tells me that like most people in
Bahu kauka she grew up in poverty when
she was 12 her father was murdered by a
local paramilitary gang
Sonia went looking for Revenge but never
found it
what you found instead was love
16 years old she fell for the regional
commander of Los caparos
a man who had grown up poor like her
[Music]
attention
against her mother's wishes Sonia ran
away got pregnant and gave birth to the
Commander's children
foreign
respect
something Sonia earned during her
initiation when the cartel kidnapped a
disabled man
and ordered her to kill him
[Music]
foreign
everything I've witnessed covering black
markets it's hard to stomach the details
of Sonia's rise to power
amor
[Music]
a part of me wants to view Sonia's story
as an act of empowerment
but all I see is a woman who's been
transformed from a victim of Columbus
violence to one of its chief
perpetrators
cocaine it remains Colombia's most
enduring and profitable Black Market
and Sonia is going to show me how she
maintains control
over gang's coca Plantation we're
essentially surrounded by Coca fields
and illegal gold mines this is also sort
of you know the birthplace of Narco
trafficking Pablo Escobar the median
cartel the cocaine that was produced it
was it all came from these Hills from
this area in fact reports from the
United Nations office on drugs and crime
suggests that 70 percent of all the coca
planted in 2017 came from Colombia from
areas just like this
is
her Hitman informed me that there are
snipers hidden throughout the Hills
[Music]
it's not long after that I finally see
it
the crown jewel of Sonia's power
producing cocaine surprisingly isn't
complicated
coca leaves are picked by hand then
mulched together then mixed with cement
gasoline and other chemicals to produce
a raw coca paste
in the past most of this product was
sent North to the US but more and more
paste is now heading south to the
burgeoning Brazilian Market I just came
from
[Music]
these local farmers are paid to feed
this growing Global demand though they
have little choice
there's a saying in this region whoever
does not so has to go
30 years ago Pablo Escobar controlled
all the Coca grown around here
today
Sonia helps manage some thirty thousand
acres
but Los caparos are outnumbered and
outgunned by rivals
they need fresh soldiers and they need
them fast
is
foreign
[Music]
recruited
it means something very different in
this region
many caparos members are actually
kidnapped
they're not volunteers they're victims
is
the case of the eight teenage soccer
players who recently disappeared in
baukau shot millions of Colombians
but Sonia knows what happened to the
players
because she was the one who ordered
their kidnapping
[Music]
TV
thank you
foreign
despite everything she's told me I'm
still shocked to learn that many of
Sonia's Narco soldiers are innocent
young men her gang kidnapped
you know
these Horrors are all in the service of
the product another kilo of coke is
ready for transport
that's when Sonia's bodyguards tell her
she too must go with so many rivals they
can't allow their Commander to remain in
one place for long she's the boss she's
the most valuable thing here she gets
killed then the guys that are in charge
of her protection will probably get
killed as well
foreign
and why not
for far too long it's been mostly men
profiting from the multi-billion dollar
drug trade
of course despite his riches
even Pablo Escobar died in a hail of
gunfire on a rooftop in Medellin
is
foreign
[Music]
just weeks after I left
the Colombian military killed the leader
of Los caparos
and captured one of his chief
lieutenants
Sonia's lover and the father of her
children
[Music]
seven the eight kidnapped teenagers were
freed
and the remaining members of Los caparos
are on the Run
including Sonia whose whereabouts are
unknown
today the Colombian government has
declared the gang thoroughly dismantled
[Music]
narcos come and go that's part of the
deal live fast Die Young
but more and more the black market often
reflects Trends in the legal ones it's
like a dark mirror
so it's perhaps not surprising that
women are pushing for equality in the
most ruthless workplace of all
and they're either desperate enough or
crazy enough to do the unthinkable
in their Pursuits of money and power
progress
can be a
[Music]